this past week in wall street a bunch of
redditors were able to
out wall street wall street they
basically said
reddit or not here we come you can't
hide we're gonna
find you and make you want me and that's
exactly
what happened in wall street shout out
to the fuji's for that very apropos song
so on today's episode of sas talks money
here's what we're gonna do we're gonna
break down
exactly what happened in wall street
into three
main components number one the key
players in this saga number two
what happened and what will happen next
and number three most importantly
how this affects your money let's talk
money all we talk is
all right so let's get into exactly what
in the world happened in wall street
this past week and try to make some
sense from it
and let's start with who the key players
in this saga
were first and foremost the protagonist
or a main
character or characters in this entire
story
would be none other than the reddit
account wall street bets this is
basically a forum
where individual investors discuss hot
stocks that they like so there'll be
more on that
throughout this episode more to come on
that the second person or character
in this story is obviously wall street
or specifically these wall street firms
or hedge funds namely citadel securities
melvin capital and citron research these
firms got burned
real bad by trying to short the market
and short certain stocks
ain't nobody feel bad for them now the
next cast of characters here are these
meme stocks
that these hedge funds were trying to
short namely
gamestop or the ticker symbol gme we've
all heard of them they've been all
throughout the news
throughout the week gamestop they're
basically like a blockbuster
video but for video games we can go in
test out video games buy video games
they're sort of a fledging company that
is sort of skirting by during the
pandemic
but they're not the only company that
was being shorted
other companies include amc the movie
theater express
where i used to go shopping in the 90s
bed bath and beyond where my mom loves
to shop
you got blackberry the phone that i had
back in 2002
and last but not least tootsie roll
tootsie roll is a public traded company
that has candy so these are some of the
companies that were being shorted and
they've taken on
the name the meme stock so you can check
out the memes
right there who else was a part of this
saga well
trading platforms namely robinhood
robinhood is sort of the
unofficial stock trading platform for
wall street bets but they were not the
only firm
to get caught up in the drama you had
firms like schwab and vanguard that
experienced
outages during the frenzy of trading
then you got
basically business leaders taking a look
at what's going on and they're basically
saying
what the hell is going on given their
opinion namely you got elon musk
you got mark cuban you got famed
investor
shamath palapatiya we'll talk about him
in a second
you got michael bury famous for the big
short you got the wolf of wall street
jordan belford
who knows all about manipulating the
market he served two years in jail
for doing that you got dave portnoy the
founder of barcelo sports
he's day trading like crazy throughout
the pandemic he's got
some uh beef to pick but specifically
with robin hood with their ceo
vlad tenev and then you got steve cone
he's the new new
owner of the new york mets he's a hedge
fund guy he's basically on twitter
arguing with some of his
mets fans and new york locals and he
says look i gotta get off twitter this
is too much drama here
last but not least you got adina
friedman she's the ceo of the nasdaq
she's basically saying what in the world
is happening on here so that's a cast of
characters here
on the business leader side then you got
politicians obviously
they're saying hold on there's some
drama going in we want in on this
who's the queen of the drama well none
other than aoc
alexandria cortacio cortez she basically
says
look i don't like what's going on here
something needs to be done she's got ted
cruz on the other side of the aisle
saying
aoc i agree with you she says listen
save it ted you almost had me murdered
during the insurrection you can sit this
one out then you got elizabeth warren
you know she's all about
anti-wall street you got janet yellen
she's the new
uh treasury secretary first female
treasury secretary
she used to be chairman of the fed she's
checking out the situation
and this whole saga goes all the way up
to the desk of the president united
states
you got that biden administration
basically saying we are monitoring
the situation so it starts on a reddit
account ends up in wall street
you've got trading platforms
experiencing outages you got major
business leaders weighing in on it
and then it goes all the way throughout
to the president of the united states
quote unquote
monitoring the situation that takes us
back to the beginning
to what i talked about the main
character here which is this reddit
account called wall
street bets so here we go so you gotta
understand what they were able to do has
never
been done before a collection a
collective
of amateurs were basically able to take
on the wall street hedge funds
and win this has never been done before
so this basically the story has
taken on a very much david vs goliath
feel obviously
the reddit account being the david and
the hedge funds being the goliath and
you know who won that one you know who
won that war
well david david beat goliath is exactly
what is happening
here today all right so those are the
key players in this saga now let's talk
about what
actually happened and let me give you a
play-by-play as
everything this past year it all starts
with the pandemic
the coronavirus hits the stock market
plummets it goes from almost 30 000 down
to 18
000 and all they say you know buy low
sell high and a lot of
new investors enter the marketplace so
that tees this
entire situation up so enter this wall
street bet form a lot of new investors
day traders are basically saying let's
take advantage
of the lowest market the stock market's
been in almost a decade let's start
investing they're starting to invest and
they're starting to invest in
and they're talking on this form so that
sets the stage for exactly what happens
then meanwhile you got these hedge funds
doing what they do
looking to take advantage and manipulate
the market and certain basically
short certain stocks so that's how they
get started and if you're not familiar
with short selling
let me just give you a quick little tip
with that it's basically betting
against the stock you don't like it you
don't own it you don't want it
you're taking out debt essentially to
short
the stock and that's how you can lose
very
badly when the stock goes up more on
that in a second
so these big hedge funds are basically
shorting these stocks and these
redditors
start to take notice they say look we
don't like these
wall streeters hedge funds taking
advantage of us little guys
let's try to fight back so they were
motivated and galvanized
to basically take on the hedge funds so
why uh you know why are they looking to
take on the hedge funds obviously
they're sick of the
corporate greed the manipulation of the
market and they're basically going to
give them a little taste
of their own medicine so basically
here's what's happening here's what's
happening
the the hedge funds are shorting the
market these guys are trying to
fight back and they get galvanized by
none other
than elon musk elon musk is no fan of
short sellers
because basically there were millions of
short sellers who were trying to short
tesla we all know what happened
with tesla since the pandemic they've
skyrocketed
to the moon a little shout out to the
spacex right there so basically
elon musk is basically saying listen i
don't like any part of this he quote
unquote says this
you can't sell houses you don't own you
can't sell cars you don't own
but you can sell stock you don't own
this is bs
shorting is a scam so that's elon musk's
thoughts on this
obviously the redditors pay attention to
his every word they're basically saying
yeah we agree with this
let's fight even harder against these
hedge fund short sellers
and then elon musk sees what's going on
and he tweets one word he goes
game stunks game stocks you've seen the
meme with the stunks
out there so he tweets that next thing
you know game stocks
stock price goes from two dollars and
fifty cents to five dollars
to fifty dollars to as high as five
hundred
dollars two dollars to five hundred
dollars this is crazy
obviously the stock is now cratering
these days but that's what happened in
this past week
so citron research one of those hedge
funds that i talked about that was
famous
for short selling they kind of egged on
some of these reddit investors here's
what they said
game stock buyers are the suckers at
this poker game so they sort of poked
the bear of these reddit investors which
only
encouraged the wall street bench
community to buy even more
game stock stock so basically what ends
up happening is these short sellers do
you know how much they lost do you know
how much they lost
not a billion not 5 billion not 10
billion
over 20 billion dollars
on gamestop alone that's a lot of bread
right there it's a lot of games
so basically the hedge funds are losing
money these redditer guys are making
money one guy turned
47 000 into 47 million dollars this is
unheard of
this is crazy so shout out to that guy
tip of the cap i hope you sold
at the top and actually made some money
turned in 47 000
to 47 million this is unheard of this is
crazy citron research is obviously not
happy about losing billions and billions
of billions of dollars
they basically say that the reddit users
are a quote unquote
angry mob and they vow to quit
publicly commenting about gamestop
yeah no you're going to publicly
stop commenting you just lost a few
billion you might want to
zip it up for a little bit citron so
basically that's what happens and then
you got
robin hood robin hood's stuck in the
middle we all heard that song
stuck in the middle with you you got
clowns to the left of me you got jokers
to the right
here they are stuck in the middle and
why is robin hood stuck in the middle
why because they get their funding from
these big wall street firms so they
don't like that they're getting shorted
but all their clients
are these individual investors so
they're stuck in the middle and they got
to pick a path
so basically what happens is they stop
trading they halt trading they basically
say
you can no longer buy the gamestop stock
you can only sell
now i'm not sure how well-versed you are
in the stock market but if you can't buy
and you can only sell the stock price
will only go down that's just basically
how that works
so robin hood is starting to get a lot
of hate you got dave portnoy basically
saying
what the hell is going on here these
guys should go to jail you got fed
regulators sec
all commenting on what's going on the
politicians are weighing in aoc is
saying
well you know how come these hedge fund
guys can treat the economy and the
market like
uh like a monopoly game but all of a
sudden when the reddit guys want to do
it
you want to try and complain and take
your ball home so that's what's going on
there's a lot of drama out there
basically robin hood gets a lot of heat
and
in essence elon musk who was sort of
stirring up the controversy actually
does a public phone call with vlad
tenniv the ceo of
robin hood and says dude what's going on
here please explain this
to me so vlad obviously he's been on the
news he's been on cnbc he's been
everywhere
trying to explain his position on this
he's caught between a rock and a hard
place
because again he answers to wall street
but he also has to answer
to who his clients are on robin hood
these individual investors
so where does this all go from here i
feel like it would be appropriate to
tell you
a quote by the co-founder of reddit
himself
his name is alex ohanian he is the
co-founder of reddit he tweets
the gamestop squeeze is the public doing
what they feel has been done
to them by institutions he goes on to
say
this is something to believe in so the
founder of reddit is basically saying
look
redditers i'm behind you this is dope
what you're doing
so the wall street bet uh the wall
street vets community here let me say a
few words about them
they are a new powerful force
to be reckoned with that's for sure and
thanks to technology
they have three major things behind them
these are the three major things
that these redditors these wall street
bets have behind them number one they
got technology right
they got all the information on the
internet and on their phones they could
possibly ever need
the playing field is equal so that's
number one they got information
number two they got communication tools
aka social media
aka this reddit community they got the
internet they can all communicate
efficiently together
so those are the two things they got and
number three they got
easy access to the markets that's
exactly what robinhood is providing with
their free
trading platform so you got information
you got
communication and you got easy access to
markets that is a deadly
combination or a crew of redditors can
take on wall street and they're using
those exact
three technology tools let me give you
another quote this is a quote by
chamath palipatia a tough name to say
but one of the smartest guys out there
he says
wall street bets is now the largest
hedge fund
in the world what
except it's completely decentralized and
entirely
democratic this is very reminiscent of
bitcoin
let me explain that to you and why this
whole story is so powerful
he just said this wall street bets
community
on reddit a freaking community on reddit
is now the most powerful
hedge fund in the world do you
understand the ramifications of that
do you understand that this is literally
power to the people
when it comes to investing this is
giving wall street a run
for their own money pretty powerful
stuff so with that being said
here's my take on all this stuff going
on before i tell you how this affects
your money here's my take so what i
appreciate about wall street bets is
they're serving as a
check to these wall street firms they're
not there's going to be some
accountability
this is capital capitalism at its finest
this is basically saying oh you want to
do that here's what we're going to do
all right so we're sick of you throwing
your weight around
with no concern for the individual
investor we have a voice too
so respect to the wall street vets
community for making this
type of bold action happen it's pretty
unprecedented talking about game stock
let's talk about that stock for a second
so usually
what happens in this type of situation
because there is history in these types
of situations so basically in a short
squeeze
situation like this is exactly what
happening is a short sale they get
squeezed out
the wall street firms had to buy the
stock price back at a much higher price
um usually what ends up happening is the
stock ends up falling back
to where it came from before all the
drama started
and we have a case example with
volkswagen back in 2008
they were actually the most valued
company on the entire stock market
obviously things have come back to
reality volkswagen is doing what they do
but they're no longer the most highest
value stock on the stock market
so that's exactly what i think is going
to happen with game stock i think their
stock
is going to fall back to reality so
history suggests
that no stock can go up forever and over
time the stock price generally
reflect the future earnings of a company
aka
the price earnings ratio so that's
exactly why i think
gamestop is essentially a manipulated
stock it's been inflated
and its stock will come down eventually
if not already
but i also predict that wall street bets
they are not
done anytime soon they have now taken
their attention
to silver and silver is trading at
basically decade high
um that's where silver is at right now
and
quote me on this i think that they're
going to move next onto bitcoin
so bitcoin might be the new darling of
this new wall street bets community
subreddit account so that's that now
most importantly let's talk about how
this all affects
your money so what i've done is i've
broken down the five types of people
when it comes
to investing so person number one this
is
the day trader they're actively buying
and selling stocks this is probably
part of the wall street vets community
they're moving their groove and they're
moving with the market
these are the day traders more on that
in a second
person number two this is the long term
investor they have a buy and hold
strategy they're probably using
index funds they believe in passive
investing they're likely maxing out
their 401ks
or the roth iras they believe in buy and
hold and long-term investing
person number three this is what i would
call the look
but don't touch investor they're reading
the articles
they're reading all the the the scripts
out there what's going on they're
keeping up with the news they're
watching the youtube videos
but they have no or very little money in
the stock market
more on those guys in a second person
number four this is what i would call
the real estate investors they're all
about
real estate they got no time for the
stock market they're all about real
estate
and person number five this is what i
would call the people who are just not
paying attention they got no money in
the market they're not investing in real
estate
they got no business they're just kind
of you know himming and hauling through
life
so here's my advice for those five
different types of people when it comes
to investing
let's start with the person who's not
paying attention here's my advice to you
wake up get in the game life is passing
you by especially
when it comes to your wealth what i
would encourage you to do is start
slow maybe open up a 401k have an ira
start somewhere but i would have
cautioned you to do is not just start
buying
individual stocks or start investing and
pumping all your money into bitcoin
but stop pretending that the market
doesn't exist stop pretending
that the stock market doesn't exist that
the real estate market exists or build a
business because these are the only ways
that you're going to build
wealth long term so pick a path and
start slow
but get in the game stop being in the
sidelines
person number four the real estate
people i get it you love real estate
you're all about real estate
you're looking at buying houses or
rentals or you know fixing up properties
you're all about real estate
cool i respect that i wish you luck with
that but there is something called
diversification
there's something also called being
house rich and cash poor having
all your money tied up in your house is
not a financial
plan that's just basically being stuck
like chuck with a house
and maybe a mortgage payment maybe not
but having no money in the marketplace
so my advice to you is diversification
have a 401k
have a roth ira start investing in index
funds don't just pretend that the market
doesn't exist
and just invest in real estate that's my
advice to you person number three who is
the look but don't touch
what are you waiting for you know they
say the best time to plant a tree is 20
years ago
the next best time is today stop talking
about the market and giving your
opinions and start investing
you know they say the number one way to
build wealth when it comes to the stock
market
the number one way it's not you know the
rate of return
or the price earnings ratio on a stock
or the
the syllabus or basically what's going
on with the stocks or the mechanisms of
the stock
the number one way to build wealth in
the stock market is actually putting
money
in the market you can talk about it all
day long but if you have no money in the
market
what are you doing it's a bunch of hot
air so my advice to you is get off the
sidelines and get in
the game person number two the long-term
investor this is actually me
technically i'm a long-term investor i
my first stocks that i ever bought my
401k
my roth ira was right during the
financial recession i heard
buy low sell high we all heard about
that i started investing in 2008 i knew
nothing
about investing but i'm glad that i've
basically done the long-term strategy
because obviously there's been a bull
market
for the last decade up until the
coronavirus but the long-term investor
that is a very good strategy but here's
my advice to you the long-term investor
take on maybe a little bit more risk
maybe you take five percent
10 of your overall asset allocation and
you try something a little more risky
maybe
you look into bitcoin maybe you look
into gold and silver
maybe you look into commodities maybe
you look into something
a little more riskier so you get a
little more reward or bang for your buck
but for the most part if you're doing
long term investing
i salute you kudos to you keep it up now
let's talk about person number one who
was the day trader
this was the person who's probably on
wall street bets all over this gamestop
thing i hope you made money
on that stock but here's the flip side
to the people who are doing the day
trading did you know
that 90 of day traders do not make money
let me say that again
90 of day traders don't make money means
they lose
that money you know i'm all about saving
that money so if you're one of those
active day traders
i caution you about spending all your
money or maybe putting all your money on
one stock i'll read you a quote
here's one guy he's a wall street bet
reddit community member he says
put a hundred percent of my portfolio
into game stock
because of you idiots is he the idiot or
the people telling him
to put all their money into game stock
the idiots i don't know
but i hope he got out all right so as
far as the strategy goes some people
will make money quick but most will lose
as we discussed 90
of day traders don't make money so
here's the deal
the get rich quick thing does not work
that is not a long-term strategy
so i hope you do have a long-term
strategy
and for those of you if you happen to be
in this wall street
bets game stock you know community going
up
going up against the hedge funds number
one i salute you number two
keep it up but number three be smart
about it this is not about
the when it comes to investing and this
is not a sprint this is a marathon
so go easy my friends so that's it i
hope you appreciated this episode if you
want more of this type of information
check out this episode right here where
i teach you how to invest in the stock
market
today because things have changed if you
have not subscribed to valuetainment
economics
you can smash that button right down
there below and give that like a little
smash
as well and as always save
that money to invest
save that money all we talk is money all
we talk is